Speaker 1: All right, it's that time of the week,
let's get to your emails, emails, trying something
a little different, not voicemails and not two or
three audience questions, but just kind of a run
through the emails. Some people who like me, some
people who don't like me, we've gotten used to
that. First emails from Jesse. Jessie says, David,
did you notice how Fox News was so careful about
not giving medical advice when it came to covid
vaccines? But now they are unashamedly promoting
ivermectin, a deworming drug, despite the lack
of conclusive evidence of its effectiveness in
treating covid. Whatever happened to talk to your
doctor about your unique medical situation? Yeah,
it's not actually just with this. I mean, when
when we still didn't have reason to think that
hydroxy chloroquine was an effective treatment
prophylactic or for active infections of covid,
you still had Sean Hannity saying some guy I
talked to, some doctor says take it with a xpac
and zinc. You had Laura Ingram talking about it.
She was talking about it even relatively recently.
It's not unique to ivermectin. And these are
these are just the hypocrisies. We are about small
government, non interventionism, except we want
to ban masks, mask mandates, and we want to ban
vaccine requirements. And on and on and on. You
guys know the drill in terms of the hypocrisy and
the double standard. And this is a particularly
dangerous one. And we see it having its effects.
We talked earlier in the week about a
police officer, police captain, in fact,
who was on ivermectin, didn't get vaccinated, died
of covid. And there are many examples of the same.
So it's very dangerous. And unfortunately, I don't
think it's going to stop anytime soon. Part of it
is people people are drawn to conspiratorial
thinking and the idea that the truth is being
hidden from them and you have to find who will
give it to you. The idea that the truth will
come from right wing corporate media network Fox
News is sort of funny on its face, but that is the
situation. And you're absolutely right, Jesse.
Let's go next to an email from Christopher.
Christopher says, Is it in the interest
of anti vaccines to be so loud about their
beliefs? If you don't want a vaccine, you should
be hoping that the vaccine uptake is really good.
So it will be less likely that there will
be mandates. Yet most of them are against
lockdown's masks and evangelize as publicly
as possible about how vaccines are bad,
creating a situation where they will be under much
more pressure to get a vaccine. Can you help me
understand what their strategy is? Thanks, Chris.
Well, Chris, you've pointed out one of the main
inconsistencies or absurdities of these right
wingers throughout the pandemic. They want to end
the pandemic as soon as possible, but they refuse
to do the things that will likely help us end it,
socially distancing when when reasonable masks,
when logical vaccines, one available mask your
kids in school until they can get vaccinated.
Right. All of those things they say we want to end
the we want to end everything, but we're not going
to do anything in order to help make that happen.
And what you're pointing out is absolutely
brilliant. If it were really about we don't
want to get vaccinated, let everybody else do
whatever they want, they would be best advised to
shut the hell up, let people get vaccinated and
so they can slip under the radar unvaccinated,
which is what they claim that they want to do.
But many of them say it's not really about them.
They say it's about tyranny. They say it's about
government overreach. And so they will claim that
it's not just I don't want to get vaccinated.
It's no one should have to get vaccinated.
And that's why they oppose the requirements,
mandates, whatever, whatever the case may be.
You're right in that if they just wanted to be
left alone and don't care about others getting
vaccinated, they should zipped their lips and just
quietly not get vaccinated. Hope the vaccination
rate goes to 80, 85, 90 percent, and then no
one's going to come to them with a requirement.
Employers are less likely to schools, whatever
the case may be, their actions are illogical
based on what it seems like they want. Really
what they want is attention first and foremost,
and also to feel like they've won with regard
to their political view. It's not about just
I just don't want to get vaccinated.
Their behavior should be different. You're
one hundred percent correct. Let's go next to an
email from Cynthia. Cynthia wrote in and says,
Hi, David, I really enjoy your show and love the
work you do. My sister sent this ticktock where
a man claims a woman is selling fraudulent
vaccine cards and having them registered in
the system as vaccinated. I looked it up online
and it seems to be a pretty widespread problem.
This is falsifying our vaccination rate. And it
also begs the question as to whether regions where
vaccinated people are hospitalized at a higher
rate should have their vaccination sites subject
to investigation. I thought it was an interesting.
Alarming topic, it would be interesting to hear
your thoughts on the show, so I basically have to
two thoughts on this. There's a micro thought and
there's a macro thought at the micro level. Even
if a vaccination I don't know that it's true that
when someone gets a fake card, it's being entered
into the system, I don't know that if it is true,
I don't know that a vaccination card entered
into the system in this way necessarily actually
counts towards the vaccination rate. I just
don't know enough about it to know for sure.
But the most important thing is, although
the fake vaccination cards are a problem,
I don't have reason to believe at this time that
they are such a problem mathematically that it's
actually throwing off our vaccination rate. I
think I saw earlier this week we're up to like
fifty two point three percent fully vaccinated.
Every point one percent is a lot of people. And I
would be shocked if the number of fake vaccination
cards is near is even remotely enough to affect
those numbers. I'm not saying it's not a problem.
People should be punished and seriously for doing
that. You're essentially falsifying a federal
document when you take the seal of the CDC
and say, I've been vaccinated, here's my vaccine
card. But I don't know, Cynthia, that I'm so
worried about its effect on the vaccination
rate necessarily. I'd have to know a little
bit more about that to be able to say for sure,
but disgusting nonetheless. And remember, the
craziest part is with the vaccine so available,
it's easier to just go and get vaccinated.
I got my flu shot a couple of
weeks back or about a week ago,
and the pharmacist was saying, you know, they're
going to be rolling out these third doses. The
CDC is going to be recommending it by group based
on need. We have so many vaccines, we're opening
up to everybody. As soon as you get to
your eight month mark or six month mark,
if they decide to change it, you can just come and
get vaccinated because we have so many vaccines,
it's easier to just get vaccinated. All
right. Next email is from Alina. Alina says,
hi, David. I'm in Allen, Texas, just outside of
Dallas. One of the football coaches just died from
covid. How is the school handling this? There's
a mandatory look at this. There's a mandatory
in school pep rally Friday morning before the
football game Friday night. Approximately five
thousand kids in one room screaming and shouting.
Allen High School is holding an indoor pep rally.
Students who do not wish to attend can check in
and go to the cafeteria instead. How backwards
are many of these states and counties and
towns and school districts and whatever?
Someone dies of covid. So to fire people up,
you bring all the students together indoors,
many of whom I don't know exactly. You know, if
if it's middle and high school, you might have 11
year olds there who can't be vaccinated. My guess
is a lot of the 12 and 13 and 14 year olds there
aren't vaccinated anyway anyway because Texas is a
relatively low vaccinated place. Stuff them all in
a room and say, hey, let's cheer ourselves up. And
remember the coach who died of covid, like maybe
some of us are going to because we're holding this
stupid pep rally. It's it's unconscionable what is
going on at this point. Unbelievable. Kent wrote
to me. Kant said consider has sci fi tech become
today's reality, at the very least, it's more
manipulation by the people controlling Trump
Puffy Face. Recall the movie Face Off, but more
in context is GI Joe retaliation? Ken asks,
Are we really seeing the real Trump? Are these
interviews prerecorded or digital creations which
help explain the randomness of his responses,
his indirect responses to an interview? Questions
are because they matched recordings as close
as they could to the scripted situation.
This is really conspiratorial. Where is the
real Trump? Is he being controlled in public
with drugs and electronic devices? Is someone else
in his skin by cosmetic surgery? No comment. No,
we are seeing the real Trump. He's just kind of
a doofus. That's all that's going on. I you know,
often the simplest explanation is the right one.
I don't think that there is some kind of CGI trump
or that Trump's rallies and interviews are deep
faked. I think the guy is that much of a buffoon.
A few people wrote to me about the swollen face,
doctors writing to me, suggesting what it might
be. It's very speculative. I won't even go into
it. But there are natural explanations for all
of the strange things we are seeing with Donald
Trump. I don't I believe it is the real Trump.
There are people who have been saying it's not
really Biden. Biden died and it's a new guy. No,
I think it's the real Biden. I think it's the real
Trump. All right. Lastly from Patrick, Patrick
is really mad at me because I said something bad
and I might be dumb. Patrick says YouTube is not
left wing. Are you stupid or just a puppet for the
left wing shills? I saw you on Joe Rogan and your
skepticism to remain neutral is an idiot's stance.
I don't even know what he means. Yes, YouTube is
so far left, you can't see them from the middle.
If queers want to exist, I don't know what this
has to do with anything, then non queers will
invent language for them. Oh, this is related to
the Carlos Mesa thing I talked about with Rogan.
The non queers will invent language for them in
calling someone someone, a queer little Mexican
is totally in bounds according to their rules.
And you left wing EFAs are going to stop being
hypocrites and stop applying your double standard
or you will suffer the hell you are asking for.
Carlos is a gay little Mexican, and if you don't
know any better, you can thank Jesse Lee Peterson
for the clarification. I would refer to you as
the little gay Argentinean. Wow. So very, very
didactic and erudite and articulate analysis there
of my appearance with Joe Rogan. And this is what
we're up against, folks. This is these people have
jobs that could be your accountant. That could be
your neurosurgeon, if you can imagine. I mean, OK,
probably not. Probably not. But it could be. It
could be. That could be someone teaching your kid.
Think about that for a second. All right, my
friends, we have a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up at Join Pakman dot com to get
instant access to the bonus show. The
normal rates for membership are really cheap, but
I'm always willing to make it even more enticing.
You can use the coupon code better twenty one
and save a bundle off of the membership of your.